[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre quelle que soit la cause que
l'on défend elle restera toujours
déshonorée par le massacre aveugle d'une
foule innocente où le tueur c'est
d'avance qu'il atteindra la femme et
l'enfant disait Albert Camu depuis
samedi dernier les populations civiles
israéliennes sont victimes d'une attaque
terroriste massive et sans précédent de
la part du Hamas qui a causé l'effroid
dans la population israélienne plus de
700 personnes ont été assassinées dont
plus de 150 personnes qui participaient
à un moment de fête plus de 150
israéliens hommes femmes et enfants sont
retenus en otage par les terroristes du
Hamas dans la bande de Gaza des
quartiers des villages ont été réduit en
cendre et les roquettes continuent de
pleuvoir sur les villes israéliennes
mettant en danger plus de 9 millions de
civils cette violence nous indigne et
nous boueverse profondément et ne peut
laisser la place à aucune ambigé
d'interprétation quant aux motivations
de ce groupe terroriste face à ces
crimes nous ne pouvons rester silencieux
ou pire indulgent je veux le dire
simplement aucune lutte ne justifie le
terrorisme aucun conflit territorial
n'explique ses horreurs car au-delà des
communautés c'est bien la dignité et
l'humanité qui sont aujourd'hui
attaqué nous condamnons fermement ces
attentats les manifestations nombreuses
qui ont eu lieu hier en fin de journée
ont marqué et la solidarité du peuple de
France vis-à-vis du peuple israélien si
durement touché nous étions nombreux à y
être et j'avoue avoir été
particulièrement touché par la
fraternité qui s'y'est exprimée je veux
dire au nom du groupe de mon groupe tout
notre soutien au peuple israélien nous
adressons nos condolances aux proches
des victimes de ces attentats et sommes
au côté des familles des otages madame
la Première ministre pouvez-vnous
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles seront les
actions à venir de la France et de
l'Europe surtout dans ce contexte de
crise aigue je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
président